hey guys i'm abby Sharpe welcome to
Abby's kitchen so as a lot of you know I
am a bit of a fitness buff I love to
lift heavy things and spin and go to bar
class and legree I'm all over it
so when I started to see all those
commercials for like the Fitbit and all
my friends had it I was like oh my gosh
I need to get one of these I was totally
into it
but I want to tell you a little bit of a
story on how my Fitbit actually kind of
made me less fit so if you're not really
familiar with these fitness trackers I
want to tell you how they work basically
they track things like the steps you've
taken your distance your active minutes
your food your water your sleep and I
was really not interested in tracking
like my food and my sleep that would
have been pretty depressing but I was
pretty anal about tracking those steps
and when I first started out I was
pretty happy with like 13,000 steps a
day but then I started get super
competitive because that's just my
nature and then it was like 15,000 then
I wanted to get 18,000 some days I was
even getting 20,000 and that soon became
my normal I was always pushing to get
more and more and more so you'd think
that I was gonna get more fit by using
this fitness tracker but actually that's
not what my measurements were telling me
in fact my conditioning was declining my
strength was declining my muscle mass
was declining and I was actually gaining
body fat so there's a few reasons for
this and some mistakes that I made that
I want to tell you about so that
hopefully you can avoid them yourself so
first of all in order for me to meet
these super high stepping goals I had to
basically spend a lot more time during
this low-intensity walking when I could
have been spending that time on mobility
or spinning or weight training or
high-intensity interval training and I
know I've talked about this before but
research suggests that when you're doing
a ton of this low intensity cardio
without the proper nutrition to kind of
support it or of course strength
training to help balance it out you can
very easily cut into your games and what
I mean by this is when you're not doing
a lot of strength training to balance
out that low intensity cardio or you're
not nutritionally supporting that amount
of
you can actually start to burn through
your muscle so even if it seems like
you're burning a ton of calories as you
step and step and step and step on your
Fitbit if you're burning through your
muscle you're actually gonna be killing
your calorie and fat burning potential
in the long term which just takes you
farther and farther away from your
health goals so second of all I wasn't
really listening to my body's need for
pleasurable activity things that I
actually enjoyed doing I mean the
stepping routine got pretty boring
pretty fast and I just kept at it I mean
once I had met those those that gold all
those steps I was after I felt like I
was I was good for the day and I didn't
have any more room in my life for things
that I enjoyed like yoga or pilates or
spinning or picking up heavy weights so
yeah my Fitbit and I didn't really work
out but I do have some tips for helping
to make it work for you so first of all
do not pay attention to calories they
usually are overestimated on a lot of
these fitness trackers especially if you
sync it up to like your food journal
like a MyFitnessPal you often will
overestimate how many calories you need
to eat so just listen to your body
instead for those signs that you want
more activity or maybe you've had enough
so number two input your strength
training activities I know that they
don't burn as many calories or
contribute to steps but if you're a goal
oriented person like me it's really nice
to set some goals for you know how heavy
your lifting or how many reps you're
doing and actually to see some progress
in your fitness being made and you can
do that with your Fitbit number three
use it as a guide to build habits one of
the things I did like about my Fitbit
was it really opened my eyes to how
sedentary I often am when I'm not going
to the gym so it definitely did help to
instill some new healthy habits like you
know take the stairs or perks farther
away at the grocery store so once you've
built some these habits into your usual
routine you probably won't need a device
to fall back on number four I think
quality over quantity
so maybe set your goal a little bit
lower for steps than you think you can
accomplish knowing that some of your
activities may not contribute steps but
actually may be better Fitness builders
and muscle builders or fat burners so
for example you could try doing a
shorter set of you
both on the treadmill instead of a
really long leisurely walk which may
give you fewer steps but could give you
better fitness and metabolism benefits
and fat burning and number five don't
get obsessed if you're finding that
having an external indicator your
fitness is getting in the way of you
listening to your body then it's
probably not the best method for you I
know a lot of us like me we really need
some kind of accountability something to
look forward to some kind of goal to set
but there's a lot of other ways you
could do this maybe you know you've got
a friend you want to hook up with that
you can work out together you can set
goals together and you can of course
support each other if you aren't quite
getting to those goals so that's just an
idea but everybody's different when it
comes to fitness so definitely find what
works best for you
so guys I hope my story was helpful
whenever I share this story I always get
a ton of feedback from people telling me
that they've got similar experiences
with their fitness tracker and actually
getting rid of it has been beneficial
for them but I'm curious to hear from
you guys so leave me a comment below I
want to know what your experience with
your fitness trackers been like what
else have you been using what's been
working what's not been working also be
sure to give this video the thumbs up if
you liked it subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen
[Music]